la bière c'est bon pour la digestion
d'abord la bière faciliterait la vidange
de l'estomac donc ça faciliterait la
digestion par contre dans la bière il y
a aussi un truc qui s'appelle l'alcool
et l'alcool bah ça ralentit la vidange
gastrique ça donne aussi un max de
boulot à notre foi qui doit dans un
premier temps dégradé l'alcool et dans
un deuxième temps éliminer toutes les
substances toxiques que cette
dégradation a créé on entend dire aussi
que la bière améliorait la qualité de
notre microbiote intestinal c'est-à-dire
toutes les bactéries les champignons etc
qu'on a dans les intestins et qui
participent à la digestion il y a une
étude qui a conclu que effectivement
c'est le cas pour déduire ça ils ont
fait boire une bière par jour à des gens
puis ils ont comparé les échantillons de
leur caca avant et après la diversité de
leur microbiote était meilleur après
qu'avant l'étude elle recommande de
boire de la bière sans alcool vu qu'elle
a exactement les mêmes effets que la
bière avec alcool et qu'il faut quand
même en boire tous les jours et puis
selon une vaste étude internationale
menée sur plein de gens qui se lacolent
la bière ça ballonne et sa Fulla